well here's Tucker asking ASA Hutchinson
about chemically castrating children
is their gender and their parents should
be able to affirm that and the state has
no role in getting involved so how is
that different you're saying that a
child shouldn't be able to choose a
bathroom but he can choose his sex I
don't understand let me finish okay what
I said let me finish oh I hope you don't
mind well please do
and the Finish is that I told Obama they
were wrong I said it publicly that the
school districts can ignore that
guidance and so that's where I think
this the government should not be
pushing an agenda in our schools and
that's what I pose and so I want the
government to stay out I want the
parents and communities and our faith to
guide us through these difficult
decisions and I will stop with this but
you have repeatedly described delaying a
child's natural progression from
childhood to adulthood through
adolescence you describe that as quote
treatment
and so that raises the I mean clearly
you've answered the question do you
believe it's treatment you believe I
suppose that people can change their sex
because if you don't believe that you
wouldn't call it treatment would you
up
here
well
the God created two genders and that's
what I have stated
okay I don't know that I need to do much
analysis on this one there really was no
campaign the guy's not really running I
don't know why they put him on that
stage yes God did only create two
genders you cannot magically become a
woman if you chop off your penis it's
not how it works the fact that he's so
unclear on this stuff when it comes to
Children especially and the chemical
castration stuff and the drugs and all
of it like he basically Tucker Tucker
just ended something that didn't even
exist it wasn't even necessary but
Tucker did it and then as if that wasn't
the kill shot and then it was it was the
kill shot ASA Hutchinson was just laying
there as just like like a puddle of
nothingness then they got into it about
vaccines and Tucker actually came out
with a shocker here watch this
one of the powers that government did
usurp uh over the past several years is
is the right to decide what medicine you
take in the form of of covet mandates
um how did you feel about that and how
many coveted shots did you take and how
do you feel about it now
in retrospect how many covered shots did
you take zero
[Applause]
to that question
um and I don't think honestly you should
be asking people about their medical
care but that became a matter of public
policy and I do think that the whole
country ought to pause and assess like
what did we just go through how do we
feel about it now and so it's a very
straightforward question all right so
this is pretty powerful ASA Hutchinson
aside Tucker Just For the First Time
announced that he never took any covid
shots now what's interesting about that
is Tucker was on air obviously
throughout covid Fox had all of their
regulations related to kovid Tucker was
obviously doing his show from home or
remote Studios throughout a lot of it
they were forcing employees to be
vaccinated
um it's interesting to me and I would
love to know from Tucker and hopefully
I'll get to talk to him about it at some
point why he didn't say that earlier you
know it's interesting everyone has their
own first off your private personal uh
medical information is not anyone else's
business as a general rule you guys may
remember at the height of kovid when I
was on Fox La TV with civil rights
lawyer Gloria Allred and she asked me if
I was vacant and then I asked her when
the last time she got laid was like it's
nobody's business these things so I was
a little surprised that Tucker asked the
question but so be it Hutchinson just
walked right into it